nie wyobrażam sobie
żeby gościli czy to w białym domu
czy to w pałacu elizeńskim
wskazań prawomocnym wyrokiem przestępcy
a pan prezydent trochę udawał a trochę nie
że ich ukrywa nazywając to gościną
a tak naprawdę potem uciekając z ciemnymi drzwiami
pan prezydent doskonale zdawał sobie z tego sprawę
co się stało bycie gospodarzem nie ma Nic do rzeczy
bo jeżeli ktoś przebywa nie pod swoim adresem
Tam gdzie policja jest zawiadomiona
że Tam może kogoś poszukiwać
to poszukuje go gdzie indziej i wszędzie Tam
gdzie go znajdzie
czy jest to w urodziny
czy jest to w restauracji
czy jest to na przystanku autobusowym
to Po prostu z tego miejsca go podejmuje i zawozi do
tylko trochę to tak